you also mentioned the book The Great
degeneration by uh Neil Ferguson an
awesome historian he's been on this
podcast it helped you understand the
inefficiencies of government regulation
I'd love it if you can give an insight
into why government is so inefficient at
times like when it is inefficient when
it doesn't work why is that the case the
bureaucracy that you spoke to uh the
negative aspects of the bureaucracy so
we don't have enough time on this
podcast to go into it but it's uh look
there's there's a lot of aspects that
work as well right but I do think we've
gotten too big you know Neil's book that
you mentioned you know one of the things
that I took from that I read it I think
in in 2012 right kind of in the middle
of the great financial crisis was he was
talking about how government regulation
uh often was put in place to deal with
old crises right so it was never going
to solve future problems it was more to
kind of create to solve for problems
that had happened in the past and I
remember thinking about that uh one
thing I was very proud of of the work of
the Trump Administration was that you
had four years consecutively where there
was a net decrease in the cost of
regulations so to give you a context in
the last year of Obama in 2016 there was
6 million man hours spent by the private
sector complying with new federal
regulations and that's not really what
the intent of our government was right
if we have rules or regulations those
should be legislated by Congress they
shouldn't be put in by you know by
bureaucrats who are basically saying I
want to follow this objective so using
kind of the power of the pen in order to
do that so the deregulatory effort was
actually very critical to Trump's
economic success that happened in the
beginning of the administration and then
what I saw with regulation was anytime
either there was legislation or
regulation coming the people pushing for
it were usually the people who would
benefit from the regulatory capture so
you had these you know you look at you
know the great financial crisis where
you had these big banking reforms well
what happened during the big banking
reforms then you had had a big reduction
in the amount of banks that occurred and
the big Banks became even bigger whereas
I don't think that was the intention of
the legislation but the people who were
writing the legislation and influencing
it had a lot of the constituencies from
those larger institutions and then what
happened as a result of that a lot of
these smaller institutions didn't have
the ability to uh be as competitive they
had more restrictions more costs they
became less profitable but these were
the banks that were serving small
business which is the biggest uh creator
of jobs in our country and then as a
result the bigger Banks got more
powerful and what happened in the
country as a result of the the
regulations that they put in place the
wealth Gap in the country grew it didn't
shrink and so I think often times what
they say these regulations are intended
to be the result often becomes the
opposite and so you know what what
president Trump did in his
administration was they did a massive
deregulatory effort and I think they
pledged that for every uh one regulation
they put on because you do need some
regulation in an economy and in a
society uh they would take off two and
in the first year they limited eight
regulations for every one and so um so
that was just something I took from it
which which was uh I thought very
interesting and you had to really I
think you just have to think through
what are the consequences going to be of
the different actions you take and often
government gets it wrong by taking an
action that feels right but has big
negative consequences down the
road
that